here we are at this incredible chess
club here see what we have going on here
tonight on Oh lovely to see oh hey how
are you guys doing so I heard that
there's a big lecture tonight yeah we
gonna break down it's right next door
Rose holiday spectacular oh my gosh free
popcorn are you telling I free popcorn
and soda and groundhogs groundhogs
popcorn soda oh I got a state champion
missouri state champion unbelievable
what an opportunity what is this thing
start now starts now we got to get over
there all right we're at get over here
to the kingside diner here is the one
and only Mike comer is gonna be
lecturing tonight oh the kingside diner
sighs how I maybe need to get that look
that ok so here we are at the kingside
diner and hopefully doors not locked ah
it's hoping yes hey is this is this the
site of beginner breakdown
oh I can't wait all right welcome to a
very special edition to begin to break
down and this time I mean it all right
this is a secret of true happiness
revealed obviously I've gave you the
meaning of life and if you haven't know
it it's essentially getting glory but
check out meaning of life revealed and
then proceed to this episode so there's
a lot of a lot of ways to be happy it's
not as important as getting glory but
but just because you get all the glory
doesn't necessarily mean you're happy so
so as we go through the games they go
through all this we'll see how to be
happy and what it takes to be happy and
how glorious it is to be happy all right
so so I was trying to get a some glory
last weekend along with the Keith bass
who finished three and a half out of
five and won his section the only game
he lost of course was the who who'd you
lose to Keith yeah he lost a comer
alright and that's the game the game
will show okay we can't resist it all
right oh yeah all right I had the white
pieces against Keith we were both want
to know and I start out with the King's
pawn black plays 'if I've so my bishop
attacks the pivotal f7 square and so now
Keith doesn't want anything to happen he
doesn't want the night coming in like
this and taken so he's going to just
plant his night not with h6 so do you
know what the computer actually
recommends is the best move in this
position it's a shocker
no Danny do you know no no just queen
you too you're getting closed your warm
you got the right piece but we might as
well threaten checkmate cuz I because if
you try something like g6 he's not going
to be too happy right because Queen
takes 'if I've check if he attacks my
queen like this checkmate right and so
the only way to stop it is either with
Queen to e7 or queen to f6 so he doesn't
want to do either oh I don't want to do
either so Knight f3 and just proceed
normally d6 now I play h3 because I am
unfamiliar at this point with leggings
mate or legals mate or whatever so if i
play Knight to c3 here and he plays the
move Bishop to g4 do you know what
shocking move i have in this position
Knight takes pawn and you're like what
well I could take your night and then I
would take your Bishop but if he's like
oh man look at this free queen we have a
trick Bishop takes f7 check the King can
only go one spot right and then where is
the checkmate night to d5 yep checkmate
look at that can you believe it so so
you know i usually say h3 is cool h6 you
know but you know maybe developing
normal it is good so anyway h3 play play
a little passive play a little passive
and now he's playing a little passive so
I get castled now an interesting move
Keith might have had in this position is
just I'm just going to go for it g5g for
and and trying to break up my castle
because he's not committed to castling
over there he can still Castle Queen
side if need be so you might want to
just start attacking me after I'm
castled but he played the move I
expected to play Knight to f6 yes okay
all right good all right Ricky one and
he gets castled and c3 preparing d4 so I
go ahead with my plan and now my knight
takes a little stroll I play a 4 to
prevent b5 because if he plays b5 you
can take if it takes back I could take
with the bishop and this pawn is in a
pin I mean if he takes their up I get
your rook ok so after a four brings his
Queen out and now I bring in my night
back night attacks my bishop so I
actually probably retreats it and so so
Jonathan Trott's the guy from chess
openings explained says you should
always bring your Bishop back as far as
possible so that your opponent will
forget about it as we'll see in a
subsequent game it really bails me out
and it builds me out in this game as
well because look now my pawn is only
defended by the Queen and no longer the
rook alright so Bishop out I attack his
night his nice got to go back to c8 kind
of an awkward square for his night and
now I play Bishop to d2 preparing to
play Queen to see one and attacking h6
so now he makes a blunder but I make a
subsequent blunder all right so he's
trying to break open the center god
bless you tomorrow but
do we have here so so what we should do
in these positions is actually calculate
and that just move because that's what I
do that's like oh that's a bad mood i
can just Boop and then i end up with egg
on my face okay so if you go through
each different capture and really
picture it in your mind you'll easily
see the right one okay so we see if if
Knight takes here maybe he'll play
Knight takes and then you know we might
have dreams of sacking or rook and I
don't know we're in hitting hitting uh
you know maybe hitting this but you know
it's kind of kind of shaky okay and we
see well if we take this he would take
back maybe I know we can take all right
and that ways we're up upon or we can
take here this is what I did instantly
instead of going through each and every
step so what move does he make that just
like kind of humiliate Smee and gives
him an edge here yes no if pawn takes
pawn I'm going to take his night you can
take my night I'll take his Bishop now
he could probably take my pawn well no
you better save your rook and then I
would just like move up oh no I would
take his pawn and the computers going to
be like white wins by 500 okay by 5 i'm
well might as well be i'm up by 11 okay
so what's the what's the code and so but
he's got a much better move then
pawn takes pawn how else can you take
the pond night right don't feel bad I
didn't see it either o XO excellent
excellent okay alright so so Knight
takes pawn and now you know I might
still have a little lead but it's
nowhere near as big as it once was ok
alright but we can't let stuff like that
get us down we have to move forward
alright alright so so Bishop you know
gets on the same line as the Queen so
Bishop blocks aid the ponds night
attacks the night now now if you were
listening to what i was saying before i
was saying oh I really want my queen and
Bishop on the same line like this so so
it really doesn't make sense for me to
play night to g3 in this position
because then he takes and my bishop is
here now it would make way more sense
for me to play here because if you would
take now I get what I was after the
whole time but little did I know alright
but he doesn't take instead he maybe he
got his move order wrong because because
taking here and Bishop takes and Queen
takes will be ok because i can't take
Bishop takes pawn discovered attack on
the Queen because Queen can take the
bishop but unfortunately when he plays a
queen takes a five right now what move
can i play to essentially win the game
alright fantastic right and then he
would move his queen I would take his
night and then I would be I would be all
right here thanks Mario and then I would
take take it all in and I'd be doing
good ok so that's how the game and a
Keith Keith knew that I'm such a such a
great player he couldn't stand playing
any any longer against me right save his
energy for the next games all right so a
good game Keith hopefully you'll learn
something from that game yeah good good
good and now uh now here I am playing
playing the guy that introduced me to a
tournament chess p dimmer and sophomore
year of high school okay so so this is
the money game if I win I get second
place in the tournament unlike dini
Magoo co but that's okay so so I have
the white pieces and I'm feeling pretty
good all right so I start out Queens
pawn unfortunately through most of my
career I was an e pong player so I don't
know any of the traps in Queens ponds
openings so if anybody says my comer is
really bad at chess yeah for the first
part of the game you're going to be
thinking you're validated but but we'll
see alright so now he tricks me alright
that looks like a really dubious move
Knight blocks the Queen right if you've
seen this at home just the opening
you're like oh no I can't believe it
alright so I'm like do p ice I hate to
do it to you
I really hate to do it to you and so I
take and unfortunately unfortunately
he's got more class than me if I was
playing the black side and I knew this
trick I would probably slam this move
like really hard and and be like yeah
all right what does black play and keep
in mind it is all along the same line as
that lagoon's mate or legals made or
however you pronounce it this is called
for the record it's called the elephant
all right all right so so we saw this
tactic before so it is Groundhog Day ok
as we saw it before ok so so a big part
of being happy and not being unhappy
like I could go home and cry about this
game and blah blah blah or I could learn
from my mistakes pass on my knowledge
and and maybe instrument this in the
future against my future opponents but
who thinks I'm actually going to fall
for this tactic ever again the answer is
no ok so so we've seen this now we've
seen it we can recognize it and now we
can instrument it would move this black
play to win the game here all right Ben
Simon night takes d5 he didn't instantly
and so now I'm like old man obviously I
know I felt for a trap but I have to
look at the alternatives if I don't take
the Queen it's just going to be
miserable so I just have to accept my
punishment and move on with my life
Bishop checks Queen up the only legal
move maybe that's why you thought it was
legals position they don't have one
legal moon alright so King takes and
then he takes and now i'm down a full
piece for a pawn ok so once again you
can't ever give up here you just got to
keep
fighting alright so what's a move that
debt just says all right I'm down but
I'm not out I'm going to keep keep the
fight on anybody what looks like a very
natural move here efore keep the fight
on ok once you lose your fight you lose
it all all right what's another fighting
move here Bishop c4 Bishop c4
unfortunately you know even if you waste
the move and we take and then this is
going to be not so fun all right so f
for all right just keep at it keep at it
even though you're down doesn't matter
you got it you got to be scrappy all
right so normal development so he
attacks by center with f5 so now I got a
passed pawn ok just like that I'm down a
whole piece but you know you just keep
it up and you know good things can
happen you don't just play passively
just waiting for your your time to
expire you know alright so h6 g3 protect
the F pawn bishop out it's a good plan
for him if he can start putting his
Bishop here he's gonna he's going to do
good things c6 I don't know he's got he
I mean he doesn't need to protect the
square he's got it right he's got it but
alright so Rick over King to c7 kind of
weird putting your king on the same file
as my rook alright so Bishop challenges
bishop so now he does it so I protect it
in an end game without a queen you know
your king can become a warrior as well
see it's very important concept this
King has to make up for me being down a
piece you have to make him an active
active piece so rook up so so luckily so
luckily i started thinking actually it's
of just playing moves that you know I
thought it would help me so so this is a
big big threat here all right if we're
not careful we could lose more material
and I'm only I've got a pawn for that
Bishop so I don't want to lose any of my
any oh my guys are precious right now so
what is the threat on the board so first
we have to one identify the threat and
secondly do something about it my king
is currently overloaded okay let's do a
way way too much he's protecting the
night protecting the pawn so so what is
blacks tactic here yes yep so you're
going to take my night my Kings got to
take and the rook takes pawn I'm gonna
notice to me I end up playing the best
move all right so I play rook protects
the night in hindsight I was like oh I
should just protect the point but all
right I got lucky all right so look up a
much better plan for him is to double
the rooks on the D file the action file
right not really much going on on here
except that I have a pawn that's
currently not going anywhere so not much
action on the e-file the D file
definitely the actual file is the half
open file all right so night up attacks
the pawn king retreats fish up attacks
the pun g6 now now there's two things I
could do in this position right whoo all
right if you had if you had to predict
the outcome of the game white wins
blackroot wins or draw if you just had a
look at this position what would you
think hello sir you can go ahead and
take some free popcorn and enjoy the
show oh alright so
White is getting devastated here and if
you don't do something about it going to
die a slow monotonous death you do not
want to do that we want to be happy
remember all right this is a secret of
being happy go for it all right very
profound wisdom okay so if you were
going to go for it in this position what
would you do yeah Knight takes the pawn
Knight takes bishop takes even though
it's probably an unsound sacrifice the
alternative was even worse okay there's
no joy in getting a you know string tied
for the rest of your life right so you
go for it ok so now I have one to pass
pawns and a potential to make a third
one ok and plus I got I got it I got it
going on now I got some momentum all of
a sudden and look on this very next move
guess who's retreating now you know so
got to go for it and you'll be like well
you're just retreated well that was a
strategic retreat as a Jonathan
hopefully uh he really helped me out
here you want to put that bishop as far
back as possible because when you're
playing a real-life board on a real a
real board not just this computer stuff
I mean it's very hard to see this Bishop
behind all these pawns you know so and
if you're really good you trim off the
top of him so they don't even know ok so
so that's a good move alright Bishop
attacks my rook i attack his Bishop he
checks me King attacks the bishop and
Bishop here so he's kind of he's kind of
begging that his Bishop gets captured or
trapped so my king moves up preparing g4
obviously he should play h5 but he's
gonna play rook first so I'm like okay
I can't I cameras this plane g4 okay if
he's going to let me I just gotta try it
if I was really good i would calculate
but it's too hard to calculate that
alright so rook attacks my pawn the
simplest way to protect the pawn is with
another pawn just push it alright so now
I got two guys comin comin right for him
and works are very bad at defending uh
passed pawns if I was him actually in
this position I don't know what I would
do so I don't I don't even have to
calculate it alright so h5 obviously is
the best move alright so h5 so if I
trade this pawn
for that pun it's not going to be very
good you know however it takes back it's
got it's going to be it's going to be
very very bad so so okay so I cannot
take this pawn or also I would just lose
so what move do you think i have here to
keep the game afloat for another minute
any ideas because pawn takes check is
coming and that obviously is going to
make it so i only have one defender of
my F pawn so nod knows g5 does not well
g5g five on four she loses to Bishop
takes pawn so what's the easiest way to
protect the pawn with another pawn right
f6 alright so so Bishop takes check so
where's the only place my king can go to
keep them active efore okay so check
King back and as you know if your up
material trade material to consolidate
it down to a winning endgame so he's got
first step down work takes rook rook
takes well well now he's got to deal
with pawn takes f6 well actually Bishop
takes pawn takes up six would not be an
option because it's it's pinned right so
he's really should consider that but say
it gives me another check King up
and now he kind of a freaks out a
fortune Knight takes check pawn takes
rook takes but but as you see he's got a
night he's up a full night so he should
win so but we just got to keep at it all
right King up attacks the rook so now
when he plays rook tape or work to f5
check what's a great move that a white
has here Bishop right yeah so he didn't
see it so Jonathan's plan that he told
me came too late and it's actually a
double blunder I love double blunders
okay so Bishop takes so regardless of
how he takes back what move do I have
now to win the game just flat-out win
the game it's not even like rook takes
bishop pawn takes King takes and then I
i I'm unstoppable or even if he does
come and stop me I'm going to go get his
pawns while he's over there with the h
points all right so and then if he takes
back with the bishop what move do I have
I have a fork in this position yeah King
up six I don't even realize this but I
think this works too but but at king of
six yeah that's where I would have done
instantly and I can't save on both
alright so
and now he puts his night here and I
proceeded to trap it this is the only
place you can hop too so h3 and you
can't hop anywhere okay so that's how I
became second place finisher in the
chest like it ought to be tournament
alright but no fear there are some other
great games from just like it ought to
be here so our good friend uh Robert
Beekman had the white pieces so a big
part about being happy for the rest of
your life okay is the biggest thing is
never stop competing okay you gotta play
on to the bitter end all right because
once you stop competing what happens
it's over okay so there was no more
glory the glory is right up so Robert
Beekman he's going to go for that glory
until the day he can no longer do it so
good for him so let's see how Robert
Beekman tries to go for the glory night
up three c5 g3 all right he's got the
standard dragon position I like it 'if
I've so d3 prevents efore so night up
[ __ ] up up Bishop e6 night there h6 so
your bishops attacked you better take it
because if you go backwards g5 is coming
if you go backwards d 4 is coming right
so just going to take it Queen takes c4
Bishop up rook the b1 all right Black
gets castled a three takes Knight takes
b5
night up look there you're not going to
believe a move that's coming up pretty
soon here hopefully it's not this move
but it might be all right Queen to be
three attacks the b5 pawn ha like it
hate it very pretty good move if your
opponent's asleep like Mario you might
actually get away with this Bishop takes
Queen ok night attacks the bishop dharni
saw it okay rook up night up threatening
the Big Fork will he see it will he see
it oh so unfortunately he did not quite
get out of the night for huh so what
does black play to win the game
this is the gang and that's that's the
end of the game okay so so we've had
enough all right so you had a bad day
all right our bad round bad our guess
what there's always chance for
redemption all right and here comes
Robert Beekman with his big Redemption
ok so just cuz you know you had a bad
time you know I lost the night in the
beginning of the game he lost his Queen
could just keep going ok just keep on
fighting all right so here it is Robert
Beekman has the white pieces against an
1100 so he's paired up by about 300
points here so let's see how he proceeds
all right night up three we've seen this
before okay he's like I didn't lose
because of my opening so I'm going to
keep that the same just hopefully I just
won't hang my queen this time right
learning from our mistakes all right
well he brought his queen up okay can't
be afraid you can't be afraid he just
knows now not to put it where it can be
directly captured so it doesn't mean you
can't get out there and get your queen
up there just means be smart about it
learn from your mistakes Bishop takes
Bishop Knight takes rook protects the
pawn all right Queen to be three he's
not afraid to go to be three right now
because because a big hug is here not on
e6 Queen attacks the night does he see
it yes all right he's attacked again he
sees it
all right rook rook takes the D file
night attacks the Bishop Bishop attacks
the Queen uh oh oh but hopefully there's
stuff going on his head and
unfortunately Robert has a really good
move here that I believe that he misses
what move should he make in this
position hello welcome to the chest
class yes it's beginner breakdown it's
four players around 1,200 sure they'll
be mastering the middle game right after
this that's a little more advanced yeah
Queen takes b7 it's got to be the great
move it gives white a little advantage
all right instead it goes back to see to
where it's safe Bishop attacks the rook
he sees it Bishop back to e6 so so
Robert decides I'm going back to f1
Thomas is like I'm going back to see for
rook back to d1 Bishop back to e6 rook
to f1 a [ __ ] up there and yet and
they're like this is a draw and so drop
by a three awful repetition okay so so
an unlikely end to to the game but
Robert got the glory right because he
drew a higher rated player so so pretty
good and you saw he didn't hang any of
his pieces this time so so just like
that you know he progressed so we've got
to be making progressions
all right I'm reluctantly reluctantly
reluctantly will show the championship
game from the January Nate's because the
winner is none other than Harper Evan
Smith can you believe it so so a big
thing about being happy is forgetting
the grudge's right grudges out the
window because the only the only affect
you not not your opponent so so it's
always good to at least let your
opponent think hey I'm on your side you
know all right so here it is hats off
the Harper Evan Smith all right he's got
the black pieces against a chess expert
so this game might be a little more
advanced than usual but keep in mind
it's Harper Evan Smith so all right so
Harper Evan Smith is as the black pieces
and and this is this is a decent way to
play against the Grand Prix attack of
the Sicilian I like to play just a six
and kind of neutralize the bishop but
but just d5 and going for it is fine so
pawn takes Knight f6 I guess Harper is
not afraid of the move c4 liar would
probably be so instead he protects it
with a bishop so night takes are a queen
attacks the night double attack so
obviously Harper is going to see and
play e6 probably you know all right
night attacks the night so he's tripling
up on this night so now he's threatens
to play Knight takes T to chuck okay so
what is the only way white can actually
deal with this this threat effectively
all right RC two point is attacked by
the night we don't want our night to
take it Bishop d3 unfortunately would
not war well yeah obviously the computer
a computer couldn't even wait to see it
but for the record I saw it
but you're right so so Queen the d1 is
the way to do it okay you've got to
protect the pawn yes d3r Bishop b3 so
Bishop b3 probably falls to the same
thing except it's more complicated cuz
you got this check and look like the
computer the computer you know you don't
even need me anymore okay look if you
can run the class all right and now then
you're in the same hole as you are
before okay all right so all right so so
any in any case you place Queen to d1
and and yeah the computer and Harper
played exactly the same they're like
let's get our night out the c6 alright
hopefully this is the real live game it
looks like it all right so they're
getting the night up bishop up they both
want to castle so they do all right he
doesn't want to be checked along the
diagonal so he just place King to h1 a6
threatening of b5 here so he doesn't do
anything about it plays Knight up so
night attacks the night now be five I
don't know what took them so long all
right so Bishop back [ __ ] up along the
long diagonal so so keep in mind
everybody okay I don't care how many
pieces are in between the night all
right between the bishop and the king
it's attacking it through an x-ray and
this game is going to be decided because
of this because the guy lost sight of
the long Bishop to Bishop in the back it
can be a big big force so if there's
anything about taking taken from this
lesson it's a keep the bishops on the
back because nobody can see them all
right so clean up what did that thread
may thank you so what more do you think
he's going to play to stop the mate I'll
give you two choices g6 or h6 I know
what I would play a six well I don't
want to look like a fool but I map
ticking g6 all right good g6 are good
all right so Queen takes pawn sorry he
got a tactic in okay double attack all
right so Bishop attacks the Queen kind
of cool so Queen back threatens to trade
the Queen's now Harper playing black is
down so you think he wants to trade
queens no f6 of all moves Harper Evan
Smith all right so Queen back rook kind
of protects everything so night up Queen
to d5 now if i was playing white I mean
sirens would be going off in my head you
don't have to calculate anything I see
man Queen Bishop on the same diagonal as
my King aiming at g2 I might want to do
something about it the worst thing I
would ever want to do is move my Jeep on
obviously when I would one I would
probably once am I like helping out so
rook to f3 here all right so he's kind
of putting like another guy in the
position night retreats so what did that
do it said okay there's nobody on the on
the diagonal anymore in so my queen of
bishop or working is one they are
officially in the battery on the same
diagonal heading toward g2 now I give
you guys a lot of hints so when the time
is right hopefully we'll get the answer
I'll give you one more hint ken
White's King move in this position can't
move can't move all right so Knight to
c3 triple ? Queen takes rook let's see
checkmate excellent all right so it's
good so it's trapped right so after
Queen takes obviously doesn't want to
give up so it plays a knight to e for
what move do we have are you like darn
Queen the e8
let's see what the evaluation is haha
made into very good yeah I just joking
around alright so so Harper Evan Smith
when's the January nights okay so so
here are some tips alright so so you got
the glory right you won the nights where
to go okay so whenever you have a reason
to shake shake when you have a reason to
smile smile many of you have a reason to
sing I wonder that so I one of the
nights sing and whenever you have a
reason to our dance dance it up okay and
just have fun I keep competing for the
rest of your life and way you'll never
get old and you can live a glorious life
for the rest of your life all right
thank you all for coming and hopefully
you'll learn the secrets of true
happiness all right